[Musique]
comme un nouveau souffle après des mois
sans concert la musique a repris ses
droits à voisins le bretonneux la part
belle était donné avec une scène ouverte
puis un concert de groupes locaux
le food bazaar small bande était de la
partie ça fait plus d'un an que les
musiciens rongent leur frein et ils sont
morts de faim ils vont tout donner ce
soir
bon voilà quatre répétitions pour monter
ce petit concert d'une demi heure
c'est presque une nouvelle sensation je
dirais ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
n'a pas rencontré ce public là que ça va
être quelque part une redécouverte
quel massacre et skate ça fait un bien
fou j'ai moi je suis nouvelle élue à la
culture donc à depuis un an
effectivement j'avais pu quasiment rien
faire sauf la musique au parc l'année
dernière au mois de septembre et depuis
tout était à l'arrêt et vraiment ça fait
tellement de bien de pouvoir enfin
retrouver les gens on sent qu'ils ont
vraiment besoin de se retrouver deux de
fêter les choses
[Musique]
multi son style dronne saül jazz avec
une contrainte les règles sanitaires
concert assis et port du masque mais pas
de quoi refroidir le public jusqu'à 150
personnes ont pu assister au concert ont
bien profité et les enfants jouent dans
le parc et nous envoie un petit coup
tranquille venir profiter au bonheur la
musique et puis que les puits les
enfants puissent jouer quoi est plus que
profiter d'un moment de convivialité
avec les gens j'ai hâte que les concerts
debout reprennent pour être franche à 6
c'est un peu moins drôle
le couvre feu n'était pas d'actualité
mais le ton a choisi de limiter la fête
vers 21h30 l'orage a éclaté
la municipalité donne déjà rendez vous
même et prochaine
[Musique]